TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
Timothy Jordan here, again,
now with Nicole Limtiaco.
She's a software engineer on
Machine Learning at Google.
Hi, Nicole.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: Hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How are you?
NICOLE LIMTIACO: I'm good.
Happy to be at Grace Hopper.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I am, too.
It is so cool.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you
work on machine learning
and machine learning is huge
at Grace Hopper this year.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: Yes.
AI is huge in general.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: AI
is huge in general.
We heard Fei-Fei's keynote--
day one.
And that was incredibly
inspiring to hear her story
and really talk about
bias in ML and how
we have to pay attention to it.
I found that really fascinating.
What are some
themes that you see
sort of repeating there
that feel kind of new.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: Well,
I at least a theme
that I've been
sort of tracking on
is this idea of
social good in AI.
So whether that's like being
socially conscious within AI
technologies, or
using AI technologies
to do social good in the world.
It's like a huge thing.
I've been to tons of
social good sessions now,
and like it's just
really great to see
that we're putting our skills to
something that's really useful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
is it that you're
most excited about in
machine learning right now.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: So I get
really excited about this idea
of being able to
do model knowledge
transfer across models.
So like, can we take a model--
say a language model--
that's sort of what I do,
I'm a natural language
person in my work.
Can we take information
that we've done in one model
and try to use that
information to learn
a totally different task or
a totally different domain.
Or even make one
very, very large model
that knows a really generic
representation of language
and adapt that into a more--
into finer grained task,
for example.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's is so cool.
I think one of the
things that excites
me the most about
machinery, and in general,
is what we can learn
about ourselves.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: Hmm.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Which is what
cognitive science is all about,
right?
Like building these models so
that we can learn about it.
And this is one of
those things where
it's like how do
we sort of visually
recognize things as human, and
then something new comes in
and we recognize that,
as well, without having
a previous example.
NICOLE LIMTIACO:
Yeah, absolutely.
Like there are
tons of experiments
where they show that
humans only need
to be shown one example
of a word in the context,
and they get this idea of what
it means, sort of, immediately.
And so that would be great if we
could have our models see that,
but I don't think
we're quite there yet.
But we're working
really hard on it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you so
much for sharing that with us.
NICOLE LIMTIACO:
Yeah, absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
NICOLE LIMTIACO: I
love talking about it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's do that.
We're going to go and geek
out about ML some more.
You guys watch some more videos.
All right, I'll see you later.
Thanks for tuning into
one of our developer
show segments from
somewhere in the world.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
check them out right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]